un climat anxiogène une psychose à
répétition et des millions de à quand le
bout du tunnel
vacciner massivement semble être la
meilleure option à une sortie de crise
mais ne pas considérer les traitements
alternatifs suscitent de plus en plus
d'interrogations sur un éventuel parti
pris des gouvernements l'ivermectine un
nom qui rime avec hydroxy chloroquine et
qui présente les mêmes caractéristiques
une molécule peu onéreuse utilisé depuis
déjà longtemps notamment pour lutter
contre des maladies comme la gale de
plus en plus de spécialistes estiment
que l'utilisation de l'ivermectine dans
le cadre de la recherche de traitements
contre le comique 19 et logique une
activité antivirale de la molécule avait
été démontré contre d'autres virus à arn
la dengue le chikungunya et des
chercheurs se sont dit que cela pourrait
peut-être inhiber la réplication du sart
skov deux dans des cultures de cellules
dans l'effort de rapidité qui a été
menée depuis le début de la crise pour
trouver des molécules efficaces
ce n'est donc pas une surprise qu'on
essaie l'ivermectine et son utilisation
est déjà autorisée dans certains pays
européens
la slovaquie depuis janvier la
république tchèque depuis mars en
amérique du sud également ou encore en
afrique du sud et dans certains états de
l'inde
en france elle est proscrite élève
assidu de l'om snsm l'agencé française
du médicament n'autorise pas à
l'utilisation 17 antiparasitaire pour la
prise en charge du comité
sauf que beaucoup de médecins ne sont
pas du même avis et continue de
prescrire ce médicament
c'est vrai qu'on envoie davantage depuis
deux mois certains confrères me leur
apporter son étole ils se retrouvent
entre l'enclume et le marteau car le
pharmacien peut s'opposer à cette
délivrance mais critiqué la prescription
d'un médecin ans qu'elle le patient fait
confiance est toujours délicat on a eu
exactement le même problème avec l'hydro
xi chloroquine alors pourquoi défier
l'autorité
et bien tout simplement parce que
certaines études montrent son efficacité
contre le coc vide et celle ci est assez
intrigante
nous sommes au printemps 2020 dans un
ehpad de seine et marne
une épidémie de gale frappe l
établissement tous les patients se
voient alors administré de l'ivermectine
le constat est frappant
en comparaison avec les autres
établissements du département
les résidents ayant reçu
l'antiparasitaire ont été moins touchés
par le commis de 19 en australie aussi
une étude est menée en juin 2020 et elle
prouve que l'ivermectine est un
inhibiteur du virus responsable du
comité 19 in vitro
mais toutes ces études sont pour les
plus grands épidémiologistes pas ou peu
concluante pour une seule bonne raison
un faible niveau de preuve montrez-moi
des données solides et je l'achète
demain il y a plein de petites études
pas toujours bien mené avec trop peu de
patients des doses et des durées
d'administration qui varient tellement
qu'on ne peut pas les comparer et rien
en conclure pour bon nombre de
politiques le problème est ailleurs
florian philippot françois asselineau ou
encore nicolas dupont aignan exhorte le
ms à prendre ses responsabilités
des scientifiques et praticiens de renom
soutiennent aussi publiquement ce
traitement
parmi eux le microbiologiste japonais
satoshi omura prix nobel de médecine
2015 aux etats-unis
la gronde est encore plus forte brian
cole pathologiste respecté de l'état de
l'idaho fait parler de lui sur les
réseaux sociaux après avoir réalisé
plusieurs études probante sur l'hiver
mais peut-il il dénonce un vaste confit
d'intérêt pour le gouvernement américain
c'est un conflit d'intérêts car le
gouvernement fédéral s'est allié à un
fabricant de vaccins ils ne veulent pas
qu'un médicament fonctionne car il ne
pourrait pas vendre leurs vaccins 600
tombes évidemment dans les théories
conspirationnistes ou complotistes qui
émerge de part et d'autre et cette
intervention peut pousser à la réflexion
quoi qu'il en soit vous l'aurez compris
les preuves scientifiques existe des
preuves insuffisantes pour les agences
internationales de santé mais là aussi
la question du conflit d'intérêts peut
se poser pour se montrer convaincant les
défenseurs du médicament vont devoir
retourner à leurs chères études
et cette fois ci avec un grand nombre de
patients